ich habe ich unsichtbar gemacht jetzt
laufe ich an dem ihr vorbei nice mein
name ist christel hensel und ich bin
heute mit dem peter ein anziehen und ich
muss mir eben noch ein kind auswählen
und ich nehme das backup zwei glaube ich
nehme das spy kids dann kann man sich
fünf sekunden sichtbar machen wir
spielen wahrscheinlich er zwei runden
weil die zeit sonst zu schnell rum ist
und wer das noch nicht gesehen hat bei
mir ist etwas für berg poor's nur dass
wir diesen blog hier beschützen müssen
genau also dauert glaub ich genau so
lange wie nur die wollten nicht einfach
wie edward wahrscheinlich dass auch
namen richtig geschützt oder sowas und
deshalb doch auch bilder gibt es hier
unten wo ich stehe
ein bisschen versteckt der kleine willi
dir bin ich ganz cool ist ein bisschen
ein bisschen abwechslungsreicher paar
leute haben sich schon beschwert wie
kannst du so ein fake unterstützen
aber ich mal ein das ist ja nicht ganz
vergisst oder gibts ja dieses kit und so
etwas natürlich nicht brauchst du mal
eben das wette ich habe mich unsichtbar
gemacht jetzt laufe ich an dem ihr
vorbei nice perfekt
okay okay okay okay sagt ich kann mir
nach ich kann jetzt keine spitzhacke
kaufen weil ich mit ihm fertig bin schon
bei den anderen in der base aber die
kriegen mich jetzt leider ich halte die
mitte ich halte die mittel ehrlich
verdient hängt man glaube ihm dafür ihr
ganzes eisen
ich glaube leben kann ich nicht apa
vielleicht aber doch schade aber es hat
sich auf jeden fall rasche madonna kommt
einer vorsicht ok weiter lasse mich
öfter opfer
wer dann halb halb so wild wir bringen
das hier schon ja ganz entspannt habe
sich noch nie als teampartner gehabt
außer bei der runde schob es gibt für
dich wenn peter übrigens nicht kennt
allerdings natürlich ganz oben in der
beschreibung check zum haus und wir
regeln das hier ganz easy jet habe ich
noch gar nicht vorproduziert kennst du
matten jörg-peter jeder kennt man den
job
ich habe recht die leute mit dem pc
sprache pixo befindlich zusammen
aufnehmen dann sind wir mal und ach ja
stimmt ja ja da war das mit jud
ausgesprochen gut
oh mann war dies mit dem release des
trololo der troika
das ist ja ganz schön lustig oder sowas
jetzt also blau ist es blöd kann wenn
man pro tag im bett
du willst die minijobs necken und kein
bett mehr weiterkam bergmann konnte es
sehen und einfach dem rot habe ich es
ist der fun team grün anja als ob
datenbogen gehabt verdammt ich wollte
extra schon abhauen weil ich wusste dass
ich das überlebe aber dass mich runter
geschossen verdammt bei einer kommission
ist achtung ich pass auf mein vater hat
achtung achtung achtung hat ihn auf
distanz gehe aufs festland
miniröcke und dann mache ich hier ein
bisschen sky action also weil in meinem
kind kann ich mich fünf sekunden
sichtbar machen
man kann jedes kind nur glaube fünfmal
aktivieren oder so was formal ist
richtig du hast schon direkt so pass auf
jetzt ist rot noch eine körperschaft
reduziere ich will jetzt hier den
inspire machen welchen grünen hatte im
bogen der oder natürlich ein ding direkt
guckt schon so drahtig das leichter wenn
ihr mich dumm findet ich bin einfach
runter gesprungen wollte irgendwie so
cool in der luft runter boxen aber bin
einfach selbst auf gestorben mit gelb
ahnden bogen vom zak düsseldorf
weil ich mein grün bei den weiß ich
nicht mehr
also ich hab die ganze also diese einen
der auch immer so nein da ist finsterer
tod alter wellen
das ist ein problem für uns nun ein ohne
eine magic stick das immer so scheiße
allerdings wird es am bogen macht das
peter lass dir einfach nichts sagen und
hole diamant bogen so ist es okay da
kommt auf einer ca
das bist du gewesen verdammt ich will
mich jetzt hier so richtig gepackt alter
okay so
probierst du so richtig ist so cool
durchzulaufen erhält man isst du uns die
kommission ist die kommission zu
funktion ist das mich vor lachen nicht
vorbei da ist heruntergefallen sind alle
schnell mal was zu essen
falls wir durchkommen hoffentlich war
das als einer mit drogen hat noch nicht
mit dem bogen negativ verändert ich
hoffe auch der kleine chip die der haut
ab haut ab haut ab
ok jetzt sind sie beide ohne equipment
jetzt jetzt stellen ihr team wir müssen
natürlich auf das andere team im auge
behalten weil dass sie sich dann nicht
auch noch einer der team rot klar weil
der weiß die ganze zeit in ruhe gelassen
kann schon sein dass ok verdammt das war
nicht gut das war nicht gut
ich bin nicht ganz zurecht also nicht
ganz zusammen
ich wollte irgendwie werde ich die ganze
zeit fließt darauf fixiert dass ich mein
kind irgendwie sind für ein holzdach
deshalb den übelsten crêpes hier aber
wir regen uns trotzdem aber scheiße ich
habe meine blätter geholt der champion
hat sich der hoch gebaut ich glaube der
hat
ich glaube den bogen neutral oder ist
was negativ was dein wort
das ist neutral hab es schon 100 oder
gott weil dahinter dir wie du da
hingekommen ist alter ich habe ich war
gerade fertig gleich noch einer
hinterher dich oh gott was ist los mit
dir
ja ich wollte hier mischen er ist unter
leute
ich muss die facetime richten daran
liegt es glaube ich dass sie werke
so deutschen die lampen von tieren grün
wurde zerstört jetzt das heißt keine
schönen ausrasters war der von tim roth
wie stark der kollege außer uns ja dann
können wir ja der videoclip sein wenn es
auf jeden fall denn dann probiere ich
mir ich will jetzt irgend eine coole 2
action machen die für die ich das kitsch
brauche ich bin jetzt über wildes
überraschende okay sie laufen jetzt zu
team blau weiß mit beide dort sind aber
einer ist auf jeden fall hatte schießt
du nicht mehr ganz so sicher verpackt oh
gott hab dich auch nicht gesehen das
schafft dann schafft er nicht stabil
hast du das ich gut ich unsichtbar
ach so ja wir haben ein ipad angewendet
ist ja dass der von rot dann hast du das
oder ich auch nicht aber so platte auch
nicht weil ich gehe mal zu holen
auch jetzt baute sich hoch nicht sein
ernst nein alter noch im bogen ich habe
gold klar aber aber wenn er jetzt nicht
irgendwie gut reagiert in meinem auge
vielleicht wieder abbauen
hab mir gewogen geholt und jetzt jetzt
kann nichts machen nicht stoppte perfect
darum steht erkennen
ich bin unsichtbar für ihn unsichtbar
anni hat mein schwert wir sehen
natürlich abgesehen war peter kupfer
gold
vielleicht kann ich ja noch schnell
runter schmeißen
ok ok ok wo läuft da hin zu team rot
wieder bei rot er ist einfach nur
gefallen wollen wir noch wir probieren
oder ebene runde wo alle gegen sich
selbst spielen ja leute hier sind die
gerade in der eigentlichen zweiten runde
aber es hat viel zu lange gedauert wir
sind gerade bei 20 minuten aufnahme und
das leben noch einige leute würde
einfach sagen das war's von heute auch
mal ein bisschen unkonventionell so
volkes zu beenden aber ja dann hoffe ich
dass euch gefallen hat schickt peter aus
und dann sehen was man nicht mal ihr
zinsen